щонайменше 16 людей загинуло в середу
вранці в центрі Броварів під час падіння
глікоптера держслужби надзвичайних
ситуацій гелікоптер рухався з Києва на
його борту знаходилося керівництво
Міністерства внутрішніх справ України в
тому числі міністр Денис Монастирський
його заступник Євген гінін та
держсекретар Міністерства Усі вони
загинули засвідчення вочевидців
гелікоптера згорівся над броварами та
впав на подвір'я дитячого садочка
загинуло Щонайменше троє дітей та
співробітники дитячого закладу ще 29
людей доставлено в лікарні міста та
області
почули тільки що взрив вибігли дочка
побігла по внучку внучка ходить у
садочок забрали а там уже горить усе і
машини коли 19-го вдома горять да чули
воно летіло сначала
да воно Ми почули бо в квартирі на
першому поверсі чули що такі гул а потом
резко Бах і всьо і Огонь і пламя в
садочку і загорілося дали цукерок
заспокоїли їх записали імена подивились
їх спитали що болить що не болить у них
нічого не боліло були такі подряпини і
синці оброботали перекістю наклали
пов'язки знайшли батьків вихователів та
віддали зовнішньому другому щось стоїть
він е-е тут живе питає що трапилося він
каже впав щось впала на оцей дитсадочок
він тут почав допомагати
виточив звідти трьох дітей віком 6-7
років
і їм допоміг і потім Він мені подзвонив
сказав щоб я прийшов було дуже багато
машин вони заважали проїзду сюжетним і
ми допомагали їм переставляли
більше 20 людей знаходиться в лікарні в
тому числі діти декілька з них в
реанімації зараз продовжують ДСНС свої
роботи по розбору Завалів Дай Боже щоб
е-е по цій те що приносить не було але
все ж таки працюємо швидко для того щоб
якнайшвидше їх стати перекриття і
підпали в дитячому садочку одну сенсі ми
підтверджуємо загибелі керівництва
Міністерства закордонних справ України
міста Хмельницького також заступника
расстояниями нарештіатора Міністерства
внутрішніх справ
дітей де робота або ідентифікації всі
діти зараз знаходяться в іншому
навчальному закладі з ними працюють
відповідні служби також туди приїжджають
батьки складаються списки поки що такою
інформацією не зникло відомості немає
але продовжується робити по розбору
безпосередньо Завалів в садочок
[музика]
[оплески]
служби безпеки України національної
поліції дбр Зараз будуть працювати одним
вам сказати що дуже буде велике об'єм
свідчить цих дій щоб з'ясувати всі
обставини але є прохання до вас за всіх
і для людей які Бачили Ти провіт вартові
Та ми розуміємо що він тривалий період
часу оті на низько лист
будь ласка звернутися до Національної
поліції до лінії 102 або до місцевих
поліцейських обов'язково поїдемо до вас
і запишемо це те що ви бачили Це дуже
важливо Я об'єктивного розслідування але
казати що той вертольота це можна казати
лише після проведення відповідних
експертів
»
.»
[музика]